[Music]
good morning guys time is currently 4 40
a.m in the morning and today is the
first day of general surgery surgery
starts a lot earlier than other
specialties in medicine so i'll need to
be in the hospital at eight o'clock this
morning i'll do work until seven o'clock
at seven i'll have breakfast then i'll
get ready to go to hospital
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
[Music]
this is the room where patients get
anesthetized before their surgery
[Music]
punches
[Music]
okay guys i'm back home now and the time
is
seven past four p.m in the afternoon and
i'm exhausted because i've been in the
hospital since eight o'clock this
morning so i've been in the hospital for
eight hours but i had such an amazing
time today in the hospital because i got
to scrub up and suture a real skin on a
real patient in a real surgery this is
my first time ever because we usually
practice in plastic models this is like
one of the milestones in a medical
student's life and i hit that milestone
today so i'm very happy about that i had
such an amazing time in the theater
because
all the theater staff so all the
surgeons and nurses and theater
practitioners they were all very helpful
and so keen to teach when the people who
work in that speciality are just so
lovely to you it helps you like that
speciality even more now i would
actually consider general surgery as a
courier option because i had such a good
time so i saw two operations today the
first one i saw was cholecystectomy
basically removal of your gallbladder
and the second operation that i saw was
femoral hernia repair which caused a
small bowel obstruction basically the
hernia is preventing all the food in
your small bowel to not able to move
forward that hernia was repaired and all
the poo or food in the bowel now can
move
freely and
go through the anus and become your poo
in the toilet
the one i got to suture in was the
femoral hernia repair and i haven't had
any time to eat anything yet i'm just
going to go downstairs and have my 4 p.m
lunch dinner
[Music]
good morning today's second day of
general surgery and today's plan is
going into hospital finding a patient
who's admitted on the general surgery
speciality and examining them taking a
history from them and going through
their investigations like bloods and
scans so i can present the patient to
the surgeon on friday morning for my cbd
which is case-based discussion if you
want more explanation on what case-based
discussion is you can go to this minute
of day in the life of student doctor
video on my channel good morning good
morning
are you getting ready for your daytime
yes
all right i'm late as well actually i'll
go
now
[Music]
is
[Music]
surgery guess guess we went pediatrics
we got to see all the like suspected
appendicitis
[Music]
i'm with priya right now and we have an
exam next tuesday so we're just going to
do some prep for that we're going to ask
each other questions
[Music]
surprise me
not too hard
would you get with a cute labyrinth
a cute acute labyrinthitis your hearing
is affected
you get vertigo
hearing loss
that's it okay whereas in vestibular
neurons you don't get here
yes
can you name me some causes of
macrocytic anemia
non-megaloblastic anemia is
hypothyroidism
microscopy is a vitamin b12 deficiency
yeah or fertility yeah
what about microsoft academia
micros
not palestinian the battlefield
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i'm home now i'm just going to edit
today's and yesterday's footage but hope
you're enjoying my week in general
surgery so far if you are please feel
free to subscribe and if you want to see
a bit more of me you can follow me on
instagram now let's get on with the rest
of the day
good morning from day three of general
surgery i think i'm just going to join
the ward round this morning and try and
get back home as soon as possible
because i want to write up my cbd for
tomorrow and i have an exam next tuesday
so i want to revise for that all day
long so i'm not going to stay in the
hospital for too long but i'll catch you
in the hospital
[Music]
no you can put that for me thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what then began to pass a lot of fresh
red bloods on the toilet and midgar is
to the
two-thirds distillery of the transverse
hypertension for which he takes grammar
pro his hands were cool to touch and
there was no asterixis eddie can you
learn his left arm into which hartman's
solution was running his abdomen was
soft and non-distended but very tender
on the right upper quadrant in terms of
blood i do a full blood count using
these bone profiles i thought your issue
and examination were
good and i thought your plan was kind of
appropriate i think maybe the structure
potentially i would have done slightly
differently
thank you
i just finished last cbd of third year
of medical school so to celebrate that
i'm going to make some cinnamon crepes
with chocolate chips
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you